two-time League MVP is teaming up with
atnt the official sponsor of the March
Madness bracket managers on CBS Sports
they want companies to encourage people
to fill out both men's and women's
brackets for their office pools Asia
Wilson joins us right now good morning
how you doing
good morning I'm doing well
good good so each year millions of
people fill out these brackets and
oftentimes they just fill out the men's
side and here's the thing women's
oftentimes is just as entertaining or
maybe even more entertaining of
basketball being played during March
Madness so why is that important to you
it's important to me because I just
think that visibility matters and if we
can push ourselves out there and if we
can get people to fill out brackets and
you're like which bracket did you fill
out uh it's so big so for me I always
try to be like hey we got bracket
Busters we got Cinderella teams we have
the whole nine too so it's super big for
us to continue to focus on you know like
pushing women's basketball
speaking of pushing limits Michelle
Miller here I just have to talk about
gender equity for a minute last year we
famously saw one of the women's players
point out the difference between the
men's workout facility and the women's
workout facility vastly different it was
so Stark it was it was quite sad for a
number of people how is that going to
change
um to continue to be honest and pushing
it I think when people see it they
they're like oh my God it's real and I
think it the power of social media and
the power the way that the work can
travel uh is so key so if your honesty
you put that out there you see that
difference push it so people know that
it's surreal I think we get so used to
sweeping things under the rug and like
oh overlooking it or this can't be but
until you see it until it's tweeted
until it's posted and you're like oh no
there's a difference that's how you
bring people more aware I'm a firm
believer and if people see it and it
hits home uh it's definitely going to be
a change so we're just going to continue
to plant seeds and let people know that
we're not going anywhere we're still
really good at what we do and we're
gonna have some fun while doing it
all right Asia it's Tony here I want to
talk about your brackets but first I
want to tuck in a question about the big
dance itself people love March Madness
it's great watching college kids play
basketball uh what are your favorite
memories from that 2017 run and I know I
do keep in mind that the Gamecocks went
all the way so you won the championship
and I think you were the MVPs you've got
a lot to pick from
yeah
it was all right I think
I think to my coach at halftime
um she said that you know we're gonna be
good like we might go on a run but we're
going to be like okay but I was just
like yeah no we got it in the bag and
coming out in the second half I think
Mississippi State punched Us in the
mouth and I was like oh my God I need to
be real here so um plan on those big
lights is super cool I was crying on
national television I lost my
grandmother the year before so it was a
big moment for me uh but it's a lot of
fun I'll tell you that I know she was
smiling down on you so let's talk about
these brackets um I know you filled them
out can we see what you got going on for
the men's and women's
yes so I I have Purdue winning all on
the men's side uh because I just think
that they have they're like no pun
intended but they're a wheel machine
um I think that they're gonna just
really execute everything across the
board and I've watched UCLA play as well
they're gonna give us a run for their
money but Purdue definitely has it uh in
my eyes uh and I okay I have I feel like
they're good
no doubt Zach Edie the big man for
Purdue yeah absolutely right over here I
mean come on UCLA I might have to
disagree with you on there big big shout
out to Kiki yeah she's mean on them of
course
all right what about the women's side
[Laughter]
little man hands down the Gamecocks I am
going to be super biased there uh but
also they are well coached by this
lovely woman of Don Staley uh but I
can't see anyone's time and I'm knocking
on wood and hopefully this doesn't bite
me in the butt uh later on but they're
fully equipped they're ready uh they're
locked and loaded and I'm excited to
watch them play it's crazy and I'm not a
player anymore and watching them I'm
like oh I gotta watch it as a fan now
but it's super cool to see them be so
successful
Asia you mentioned Don Staley she is a
respected former athlete herself and now
carving her name into the history books
as one of the best college coaches I've
heard you talk about her before what has
she meant to you
man so Stanley is like a second mother
to me uh she calls me and say what do I
have all and like talks about boys to me
like the whole nine and I think that's
what makes herself a great relatable
coach and you want a paper or you want
to win for her and so uh she's just been
incredible and just to watch her
continue her success to shatter that
glass ceiling that us women particularly
women in sports have uh it's been so
easy to be able to say that I was coach
fire and so I am blessed
no doubt about it well thank you for
joining us we appreciate you you are one
of the best in the business on and off
the court Asia Wilson thank you thank
you
all right CBS Sports and wbd sports
coverage of the NCAA Men's Basketball
Tournament begins Thursday and the first
four starts today on True TV and if you
or a loved one is experiencing a
gambling problem
um help is available via the National
Council of on problem gambling hotline